that sort of sort of space
he's immediately like let's celebrate
like I want to take you out and I'm like
oh
how many how many dates have you guys
gone on one okay yeah we went on one
right before I left that was our first
first date
go ahead sorry so now we'll go I guess
on a second one
but he's kind of short he's only five
nine
oh that's you're you're what like five
I'm five eight that's tall enough right
not really yeah manifesting a tall man
one of the other guys I'm talking to is
six foot seven
oh wow
yeah
and we'll be going out soon it's just a
matter of like scheduling we just
haven't been able to like link on the
schedules we both work a lot
oh there's another guy who I just made
this whole Tick Tock about who was like
all about me asked me out calling me all
these pet names my love and all this
[ __ ] and then we're talking and I was
like oh you have the vaccine right and
he was like no
I was like you're not vaccinated and you
want to go out with me I'm like I'm not
going out with you you're not vaccinated
what are you sucking me kissing you
you're not vaccinated really oh I
wouldn't care I don't care in too many
Arenas where you have to be vaccinated
like I work at a yoga studio where we're
requiring proof of vaccination that's
where I'm at right now holding all this
laundry I don't do all these music
festivals where they're requiring proof
of vaccination and to me it's so much
deeper than just like do or don't you
it's about that like I don't want to
have that debate with you right like
clearly if we don't view it the same way
we're not in alignment right
so would you not would you not date
someone that was different than you like
politically no I wouldn't what are what
are your standards like what are your
requirements for a guy
I mean politically I definitely want us
to have the same view you know I'm a
black woman right so I'm not going to
date like a white Republican that would
just be a headache like why would we do
that to ourselves
okay friends we wouldn't travel in the
same circles and we don't view this the
world the same way
use the world the same as me and even if
you're not black but you're white and
you like get and understand the black
struggle fine that's fine
um but yeah I definitely want them to
have the same political views as me
because it's just why bother in having
those arguments okay I'm just gonna turn
into a fight later
yeah so what like what else
um
well they have to have a car this other
guy who didn't have a vaccine he didn't
have a car I was like how are you coming
to take me out you don't have a car you
know I'm not driving anywhere yeah
so that's like minimum requirement you
have to have a car
um I've also realized that I want
someone that has like some sort of
creative or like job and entertainment
like I have
um you have to be very ambitious because
I am very ambitious I wanted to be able
to like you know we'll spend our days or
whatever separately and then at the end
of the night I want us to be able to
come together and talk about
laughs
how does this look at something it's
rubbish I know I got a vaccine he's
gonna have this he's got she's double
right when I I remember when I was
younger and I thought what do I want in
the man because women have this list and
like the man that had a paycheck lucky
at the job I want the paycheck because
too many men at the time in my day were
out there hustling you never knew where
they were getting their money from I
want the man with the paycheck a man who
loves children and a man who respects
his mum and the man that knows about
computers
not too late it wasn't I wanted a man
that could type because I think men that
can type are so sexy I know it sounds
really weird but you see a man I mean
properly not the UC man who could type
properly it is sexy I find it sexy
anyway and that's how I feel about tools
I can't fix anything and and that's
that's all I wanted yeah you know once
you've got a ways away slip you you love
children and you love your mum and you
know you can I call them pink jobs and
blue jobs and you can do the blue jobs
but she she's still mad she you know
they have to have a car you know I don't
have a car why doesn't she have a car
yeah I don't know it's kind of I always
think that if you're an independent
Circle independent woman no matter what
color you should have a driving license
at least yeah
and she hasn't got a car but she wants a
man with this and he has to have a car
my man hasn't got a car he gave me his
car but you see people see me oh he
hasn't got a car he's got no reason to
go because what's the point of getting a
car to drive all that way around to work
when the train takes you there
but she wants a man with a car oh just
just wait just wait it gets better all
the exciting things that happen in each
of our lives right like okay this other
guy was like well I'm not rich I'm a
regular guy and I was like that's fine
but like I'm not a regular girl like I'm
I'm not so like if you're if you are
gonna date me like either you have to be
able to handle that or you yourself also
wants to not be like regular like I
don't think I could like just an average
person like that to me is boring Okay so
is there like do you care okay would you
be cool if a guy that makes less money
but he's very he's a hard worker like
he's ambitious
yeah okay so like if he was making like
let's say he just started his own
business but he makes 45 000 a year
would you date him
you wouldn't be able to afford my
engagement ring I'm getting an eight
carat cushion cut vintage engagement
ring if you make forty five thousand
dollars a year it would take what
four years no eight years how much I
don't know anything about Rings how much
how much is that about two hundred
thousand dollars girl you wanted two
hundred thousand dollar are you insane
my ring has to Sparkle from across the
streets you have blind people that's so
superficial that's like so superficial
but it's about so much more than that
it's about the fact that you can afford
that right I go to yoga with this girl
who has an eight carat diamond
engagement ring yeah the weed company
and drives an Audi so it's about more
than just it's about the fact that you
can't afford that but you ain't her
because I'm worth it she's gonna end up
cute it was a cubic zirconia that's what
she's got it's a fake one that's what
she's gonna end up with and this is this
is this is the thing is that these are
supposed to be business-minded women I
remember when I was talking to my man
about marriage you know how much my
ideal wedding costs it costs 59 Japan
including the ring and the honeymoon
1500 pounds that is it
too many people start relationships in
debt she hasn't got a car but she wants
a 200k that's ridiculous so you're gonna
have a you're gonna have a two 200k ring
and eat what chips mashed potato
what yeah I get into it here
okay well I'm just thinking like
you're gonna miss out on a lot of guys
because I'm telling you know but not not
in a good way not in a good way I'm
telling you like my dad would if my mom
asked for that from my dad my dad would
have told her to go find a new boyfriend
because there's no way in hell he was
going to spend two hundred thousand
dollars on an engagement ring and that's
something
no and that's a multi-millionaire in the
top half a percent who had 10 kids my
mom never
yeah he said he's built to the becoming
that he wasn't that originally right he
wasn't well he was making like six
figures in his early 20s oh nice so so
any any women woman with half a brain
would think this is a good this is a
good but my dad's like he's good with
money he's not like yeah she like is a
mess yeah I don't know I see it like do
you hear how she's trying to diminish
like like she's like oh well he built
himself to be that yeah like what what
have you done he's there that's what you
were he's there that's the whole point
he's dummy and it's like I grew up with
the men that you so-called one a day
like all of my brothers make six figures
that are older than me so it's like she
doesn't listen at all she feels like she
knows it all I always say would you
prefer a poor man with ambition or a
rich man with none oh a poor man with
ambition she wants a rich family poor
man with ambition because she didn't get
it she would want to reaches
I've dated the opposite and it is not
yeah